today is uh the day of the European
Council and we will certainly first of
all take stock of our strategic agenda
the Strategic agenda since versailes and
here mainly three topics the first one
is security and defense uh here the
commission will come forward in the next
weeks with a uh defense industry
strategy then the second topic will be a
look at uh energy we have moved
mountains since versailes what energy
security is concerned it's amazing to
see how we got rid of our dependency on
Russian fossil fuels but also the huge
leap forward in the investment in
renewable energies and um the third
element will certainly be the resilience
of Supply chains here too A lot has
happened uh the uh buzzwords are chips
act Or the critical raw materials act
this is taking stock of the Versa agenda
then of course uh there are other issues
we will look at for example
enlargement here um all of us we have
homework to do of course the candidates
countries have to do homework uh to
access the European Union but we as a
European Union have also to do homework
and so far um the commission will uh
work on different policy reviews in
different fields so that we can make
sure that we are ready also for
enlargement and finally migration in
migration
uh first of all two days ago we had a
big success a big success with the
agreement in Council uh for the crisis
management because this was an important
piece of the puzzle the whole puzzle of
the migration and Asylum act so now the
probability is very high and confident
that we will bring it over the finish
line but there's also the operational
work very strong uh the shortterm this
is the work on the 10-point plan from
lamp Pusa and the midterm work this is
for example agreements like we have it
with
Tunisia um and here is important that uh
we also look at the structural
improvements comprehensive partnership
with the countries of transit or of
origin investment in these countries and
also the establishment of legal Pathways
and humanitarian corridors the better we
are with legal Pathways and humanitarian
Cor
the stricter we can be and have to be
with the return of those who are not
eligible for Asylum because one thing
must also be very clear we have our
International obligations we will
fulfill them we've done that in the past
we do this now but we as Europeans will
decide who comes to Europe and under
what circumstances and not the Smugglers
and
traffickers Madam President yesterday
you met with georan prime minister as we
waiting for commission and decision and
recommendation for European Council what
will be your main message today for
georia yes we have taken stock of um the
progress in Georgia uh Lots has been
done a lot is still to do um so the main
message is take the opportunity now give
it a push forward and be very uh clear
in the reform process and the policies
that we have
agreed what's your message to countries
here people countries who have
reservations about cost and also about
reforms need to be done within
the I did not get the first part of your
question because everybody
was we have a long history of
enlargement and yes I understand that
those who join the European Union have
to be ready to join um but we the in the
experience of enlargement in the
European Union was that it was always to
a tremendous benefit for both sides not
only the accessing countries benefited
enormously the living standard is was
Rising rapidly but also of course the
European Union benefited enormously from
accession our biggest strength is our
single Market the enlargement of the
single Market is always a huge added
value for all of us
with